that are replaceable.
Okay, we're done.
So we will have you check the volume level and we're okay.
Good.
We'll start like the device time.
If you do yourself.
My name is Stephen Lawson.
It's September 19, 2011.
And we are in a room in the Valley Library
on campus of Oregon State University.
So this is the second of our interviews that is basically doing when it's falling
in this personal characteristics.
And we want to provide different things for our last one.
I want to start to say by talking about the following family.
And the interaction that you have with following children.
You'd like to start with years.
Peter Pauling.
I believe I met Peter probably in the late 1970s or early 1980s
for the first time when he was visiting his father or his parents in California
from England.
Very interesting fellow.
He was in a way the black sheep of the family in terms of his personal habits.
He seemed to drink quite a lot and was a smoker.
So I think that some of those habits had some health consequences for him late in life.
But he was a very personal, very direct person with a good sense of humor.
I really enjoyed my interactions with him.
In the early 1990s, I received a box addressed to me
at the Linus Polynes Institute of Science and Medicine in Palo Alto, California,
with no return address and no letter inside.
But the box held what appeared to be Linus Polynes chemistry, no bell prize, metal.
And I was very perplexed by this.
I didn't know why it would be sent to me.
Who sent it?
Except that the postmark was from Europe.
So I knew that it originated in Europe.
But I had no understanding of who sent it or why.
And whether or not the metal was authentic.
I called up Henry Talbeys and Nobel Prize winner in chemistry at Stanford.
He was a good friend of Linus Polynes and he and I compared the metals.
And the metal that I had got in the mail seemed to be authentic.
Except for the fact that it seemed to be an alloy,
rather than solid gold or gold plated, whatever the actual metal is.
I put it aside in my office and about a week and a half or two weeks later
I received the second package from Europe.
Again, no return address, no correspondence.
This time there was the Nobel Peace Prize metal inside the box.
So now I was really stumped.
And very curious as to why these were being sent to me and who had sent them.
And about a week or two after that second box had arrived,
I received a phone call from Peter who was an England at the time.
And he asked me early on in the conversation.
If I'd received anything unusual in the mail recently.
And I said, well yes, Peter, I have.
I received two replicas of your father's Nobel prizes.
And he said, oh good, I'm glad you got those.
He very graciously had gone to the academies and had duplicate metal struck
in an alloy for family members and for the Linus Poly Institute of Science in medicine.
Which I thought was very nice of him.
And I think he had that done.
Well, it was around the time of his father's death.
I don't recall if it was before or after, but it was right around that era when he did that.
Did you ever have a chance to talk about his scientific research?
Well then.
I never really had a chance to talk to Peter about a scientific work or his work in on chemical structure.
We did talk occasionally about the vitamin C and cancer work that Pauling was doing in collaboration with you in Cameron and Scotland.
And Peter was very interested in that work of course.
Although I don't know that he actually communicated much with you in Cameron,
and they weren't the same island there off Europe.
Linda Pauling, I've known for quite a long time.
I think I met her either a party at her parents' house in Portola Valley,
or perhaps at the Linus Poly Institute of Science in Medicine and Memorial Park.
She's a very nice person.
Like I said, I've known her for a very long time, and I knew her husband.
I think perhaps before I met her, because her husband would visit the Linus Poly Institute in Palo Alto occasionally to talk with his father in law,
Linus Pauling, because they had jointly authored papers in theoretical physics and chemistry.
And Barclay was a very interesting person, and I remember asking him to explain one of the papers to me that he co-author with Linus Pauling, and he said he was stumped by it.
Which is very amusing.
I got to know Linda a little bit better when the Linus Poly exhibition was being planned,
because we both served on the Advisory Committee.
So we were meeting together with family members and other people from the scientific community,
and Soka Gakai, quite often, to both plan the Linus Poly exhibition and at the different venues at which it can be.
So I did get to know her pretty well, and I remember when we moved files from the Linus Poly Institute of Science in Medicine here to Oregon State University,
many of the files from Pauling's office were moved to Weniger Hall before they were transferred to special collections.
And I was looking through some of those files for one reason or another, and I came across a letter from Richard Feynman, Nobel Prize winner at Caltech,
two Linus Poly, a parently response to a letter that Pauling had sent to him earlier, because the earlier letter was referenced in the response from Feynman to Pauling.
And Feynman at that time had been diagnosed with an often fatal disease, and I think Linus Poly had written to him,
suggesting that high dose vitamin C may have some value.
And apparently in the earlier letter that Pauling sent to Feynman, he had enclosed some reprints of papers that he and Cameron had written on vitamin C and cancer,
explaining host resistance and stimulation of the immune system and so forth.
So Feynman had written back to Pauling, thanking him for providing all this information to him and mentioning that he was going to share this with his physician.
Then I think in a separate paragraph, he started and I'm paraphrasing that he was had been thinking about Pauling's long career, very productive career, and all the major contributions that he had made the science and humanity.
And he closed by saying something quite clever and funny. He said, you know Linus, I'm thinking about all your achievements and the wonderful things you've done for society, but I think your greatest achievement, your greatest contribution has been your daughter, Linda.
I thought that was quite funny.
Do you recall any conversations you had with him so that he'd been reflecting back on that kind of stuff about them and what would like to be in Pauling?
Not really. I think when I was engaged with Crownland, Linda, or Peter, particularly.
We were either in social settings, which there were a lot of people involved, so it wasn't easy to have a protracted conversation, or they were meetings in which we had specific strategic goals and we talked about various businesses or relationships or so forth.
I never asked any questions about family history of any of the children actually, even though I had many opportunities, it just never occurred to me to delve into their personal relationships with their parents.
Maybe I felt it was a little improper for me to do so.
Crownland, I had known Crownland for quite a long time. He came by the Institute as did all the children from time to time, so I would see them, although I didn't communicate much with them.
Crownland became more active with the Institute as his father's illness progressed, and as we were struggling with future options for the Institute, and he was also the executive, I believe, of his father's will.
And some of the elements of that will affected the Linus Polynes, the two science medicine, so one thing that I discussed with Crownland in great detail, and we communicated about many times, both early and in writing, concerned royalties to some of Linus Polynes books.
Because Pauling had written, for instance, how to move longer and feel better, as an employee of the Linus Polynes Institute of Science and Medicine, and he had directed that out all royalties and revenue from that book,
being given to the Linus Polynes Institute. And when it came time to tie up some loose ends, concerning the Linus Polynes Institute of Science and Medicine, I was interested in whether that same principle would apply to some of Pauling's other books.
In particular, vitamin C in the common cold or vitamin C in cancer, which, of course, again, was written as an employee of the Linus Polynes Institute of Science and Medicine.
So, Crownland, I discussed those issues several times, and he seemed to be very amenable to reason, which I thought was great.
And of course, you know Linus Jr. quite well, was there any new merrier thoughts to come to Linus?
Linus Polynes Jr. I enjoy Linus Polynes Jr. very much, and of all the children I've worked most closely with him, and I think I probably know him best of all the children.
I had seen him from time to time when he came to California to participate in trustees meetings, because I believe he's been on the Board of Trustees of the Linus Polynes Institute of Science and Medicine.
Excuse me, probably since its inception, and periodic board meetings were held over the years, and I would see him, but I never really met him until the Institute was reorganized in the early 1990s.
And there was a desire, I think, on the part of the Board, and on the part of Linus Polynes Jr.
to spare his father from some of the administrative responsibilities and tasks associated with running the Institute on a day-to-day basis,
and let him concentrate on research, which really is what he wanted to do, and since time was becoming more precious, everyone felt that he should do what he wanted to do,
which was to focus on science.
So I talked with Linus Polynes Jr. after I was asked by the Board to become executive officer, and then later chief executive officer of the Linus Polynes Institute of Science and Medicine.
And Linus Jr. became chairman of the Board of Trustees. He and I worked very closely together for several years, and communicated very often about financial personnel management issues at the Institute.
In particular, there was the possibility that the former President Director of the Institute, I Meals Oopicondal,
which started a new Institute called the Institute of Medical Molecular Sciences, and that we would subly space in the building at 440 page mill road to IMMS.
And that was a very complicated and somewhat controversial and divisive issue.
And Linus Polynes Jr. and Linus Polynes had asked me, along with a couple of other people, with the Linus Polynes Institute of Science and Medicine, to analyze this possibility.
And report as to whether or not it would work practically, and if so, how we would manage that that sublease and sharing of the physical space in the building.
So I worked very closely with Linus Polynes Jr. during that period.
And then of course, in trying to stabilize the finances of the Institute, which were always teetering in those days,
and worked with him closely on public relations and kind of marketing of the Institute, and later very closely on trying to identify options for the future of the Institute,
because with Linus Polynes demise and the problems that confronted us in Palo Alto, it was not certain that the Linus Polynes can carry on as a viable research organization.
Or even if that was the ideal option for the future, excuse me.
So we spent many hours and days analyzing and debating what the right future for the Institute might be,
and eventually decided that keeping the orthomolecular medical mission as a lasting legacy to Linus Polynes work in orthomolecular medicine,
which is why the Institute was founded in the first place, would be the most appropriate future for the Institute.
So Linus Polynes Jr. and I said about trying to identify as I said options for relocation.
If you mentioned Berkeley camera, when either other people were other people extended to have family or any other colleagues out there, would you have contact with me?
Yes. Berkeley Kim's son, Berkeley Kim, Jr. I believe.
I'm Colin Barkey.
He is a partner at Coolie Guide, Warden Palo Alto, and his wife was asked to become a trustee of the Linus Polynes Institute Science and Medicine back after the reorganization in the early 1990s.
And we had quite a few ownerous legal issues to deal with at the time, and Barkey being part of that law firm that we hired to provide legal counsel and advice was very helpful to the Institute,
and I talked with him many times at that time, and of course I saw him socially as well.
I don't believe that I had much interaction with the other extended members of the family.
At about the time of Pauling's death, before he died, and after he died, there were of course many visits from extended families,
Linus Polynes Jr. family, Linus family, and others.
And I met many of the grandchildren and children and so forth, but I can't say that I really had very meaningful conversations with any of them.
You brought something up that I haven't thought to ask you about, but it makes perfect sense to it.
And we guess you had it for you, in perspective, on the transcripts, on papers from a lot of the work at the old offices.
Yes.
Yeah, it was very interesting.
I've always been in favor of transparency and access, and I thought that I've always thought that access to Pauling's papers and memorabilia should be encouraged for scholarship,
and this is a lot to learn there, and I think the more people look into Pauling's career and activities, the more interesting and astonishing it becomes.
It's really a multifaceted project.
Although it didn't have some concerns initially about when I learned that the intent of special collections, which I think is a good one, was to make Pauling's papers available online.
It struck me as a really terrific project, especially the scientific papers, the research notebooks and so forth.
But I was concerned about the correspondence being scanned and made available online for a couple of reasons.
One, many people would write to Pauling with asking for advice on medical issues.
I had cancer, they had various disease, they had a friend or relative or colleague with disease, and they wanted to know how much vitamin C to take or what other therapies might appropriate to treat this particular disease.
And sometimes they would include a donation.
And typically the way these donations were processed, the photocopy of the check might be made and then stapled to some of the correspondence.
I was concerned that there needed to be some judicious oversight in the way material was scanned and made available online because medical conditions, confidential information related to some of Pauling's correspondence.
I didn't feel it should be released to the public.
I was a little hesitant in making that material available to Oregon State University until special collections had come up with some sort of strategy to screen that material to protect those confidential issues of people that had written to Pauling over the years and never suspected that their letters or information would be publicly available on the internet.
Partly because the internet hadn't existed when they wrote, and for other reasons, many of Pauling's files, his manuscripts, a lot of the scientific work, his correspondence were maintained by Dorothy and Monroe,
the lines of Pauling's Institute of Science and Medicine. So of course those files were under our control for many years and then I worked with you and with Cliff Mead as well, who was director special collections at that time, to ensure that this material got transferred to special collections, although in many cases everything was moved in one project by moving company from the 440 page mill road address.
In Palo Alto 2, the campus of Oregon State University and to simplify things, almost everything in that move went to our area in Weniger Hall and was stored in various rooms and then from time to time, those files and Pauling cabinets and materials were then transferred to special collections.
I do have some memories of that, the green board that was in his office, he seldom erased from it. Sometimes he didn't virtually erase things because he would move too closely or a guest in the office would move too closely to the board and their code or shirt would inadvertently erase some of the writing on the board.
I once asked Dorothy Monroe, maybe out of vanity, why my name wasn't on the board because I noticed that the names of some of the Institute employees were on the board and I was curious as to why my name wasn't and he said, well that's because he knows you so well, he doesn't need to have your name on the board as a mononymic device.
Because sometimes for people that he didn't interact with regularly to associate the name on the board with the person when they came into his office was very useful to him.
And the entrance to his office was adjacent to that green board, so it could very easily look from the person to the board and back and attach the name to the person that was standing in front of him if he was unclear as to who that person might be.
I think Cliff made the former director of special collections managed the technical aspects of moving the chalkboard.
I know that there were issues about electrostatic dislodgment of chalk particles from the board if different types of acrylic were used and there was discussion about spraying the board with some sort of sealant that would forever fix the chalk to the board.
But whatever technique was used and I believe a box was built around the board and it was very carefully they didn't have standing job because as far as I can tell there was no loss of information and when the board was moved from pawns office to special collections.
Anything else?
Are you getting away from calling a little bit here but something else?
Do you reference that I want to ask you about it?
Did you work with a window on it?
That's the idea.
All right.
Yeah.
Well, I think that the origin for that exhibit probably goes back to...
I know Desacca, Akeda, the head of SGI and Linus Pong had met in Converse prior to the establishment of the Linus Pong exhibition.
So they were acquaintances and I think SGI or Akeda had expressed a desire to do something for Linus Pong or the Linus Pong Institute of Science and Medicine.
And I think, although I'm not exactly clear on this, my recollection I haven't thought about this in a while and I haven't consulted any files but I think that the...
I think that desire was transformed into the exhibition partly due to conversations perhaps with Linus Pong Jr. in the early 1990s.
And then of course, we thought it would be a way of educating the public about this extraordinary man and introducing school children to Linus Pong as a role model perhaps.
Because Linus Pong worked in chemistry and chemistry is not that sexiest subject to many citizens in the United States, cosmology, theoretical physics, things like that.
Things that Einstein was involved in or Carl Sagan was involved in seemed to resonate with people, but chemistry is a little bit difficult, a little bit oblique to many people.
So we thought that having an exhibition devoted to Linus Pong and all facets of his career as a humanitarian, as an activist, as a scientist, as a medical researcher, would be a way of honoring Linus Pong, his legacy and also introducing his incredible work to school children
and people around the world. It was hugely successful.
Millions of people saw it in locations in Europe and Japan and many locations in the United States.
It was terrifically well executed and designed, very, very diligent and creative design people working with Soka Gakai,
transformed the exhibit or designed the exhibit to fit into the available spaces in DC and San Francisco and Boston and everyone who saw the exhibit really thought it was very, very impressive.
And actually Soka Gakai, when the exhibit had finished touring, gave all the elements of the Linus Pong exhibition to Oregon State University.
Can you be very deploying a little bit? I'm wondering, did you ever go to Dear Flat Ranch?
I did. I went down to Dear Flat Ranch. They had a little guest house that was built.
I think at the south end of the beach adjacent to the main house. And I went down fairly late in Paulings' life.
I think it must have been around 1993, perhaps even 1994 when I went there.
And my visit was associated with a deposition that our attorneys were doing of Linus Pong related to litigation with health now in the TS rat.
And I remember driving down and taking him the Sunday paper, because I know that he always liked to read the Sunday San Francisco Chronicle on the funny.
So I took him that large paper and visited him at Dear Flat Ranch and got to see the house and wandered around the beach and it was very, very enjoyable.
It was a little sad too because it was difficult to see him somewhat incapacitated, but it was really a terrific experience to be there.
So I'm trying to get a sense of the space here that is a very important place to find.
And it was easy to see why it was so important to him because it was very remote and secluded.
There were no distractions, a terrific natural environment in the house, perched on a bluff overlooking the ocean.
Very tranquil space. And I think it's easy to see how he got a lot done there.
Without any internet connection or fact, I believe he might have installed a fact machine later on, but I was an ideal place for him to work and think with that distractions.
Because when he was in Palo Alto, he was a very famous man, and his time was sought by many people from many different reasons.
Old friends, colleagues, the public media.
And I think it was difficult for him to concentrate at his office at the one that's playing it to be science medicine, at least on page Mel Road, because there were so many demands on his time.
When he retreated to Deerflat Ranch, he removed himself from that contact, that connection.
So I think he really loved that time alone down there.
Do you know what it is about?
I believe the property is still owned by the family.
But I'm not exactly sure what they intend to do with it.
I don't have a good sense of what's only good for fun.
Have any ideas on that regard?
Well, I know that he'd like to watch some programs on TV, some serialized programs. He read quite a lot.
He'd love to read mystery books.
And I think we may have talked about that in our earlier conversation.
I would loan him mystery books, and he would loan me books.
Actually, a lot of his books before he died ended up at a bookstore in California Avenue in Palo Alto.
Because he would stop in that bookstore and trade books.
It was a bookstore where you could trade or sell your used books for books that they had in stock.
So I remember looking through the bookstore and finding Glenn's punk's name and many of the books in the mystery and science fiction area that he had brought in to trade for other books that he was interested in reading.
He didn't seem to have much interest in cinema, in plays, in show business arts, fine art, music.
I didn't seem to be anything that came up very often in conversation.
So he did not really seek out those kinds of experiences. I think he was happiest just doing his own work thinking about scientific problems.
The few times that I had cocktails with him in his apartment at Stanford, he was happy to sit and talk about a wide range of things.
And he liked to drink vodka, and we would typically have vodka and tonic.
Sometimes he would just drink straight up vodka or maybe with water and talk about a wide range of subjects.
But popular culture, the arts were really not, I don't think, of great interest in him.
So he was a rare individual in that there was really no division between, in my mind, what he did recreationally and what he did professionally.
And he was a scientist through and through and derived pleasure from working on scientific problems.
And that pleasure, I don't think, was to be substituted for pleasure and other activities.
I'm sure that he did a lot of things on his own, or with his wife traveling and so forth and visiting different places with his wife that were enjoyable to him.
But when I knew him best, laid in life after his wife, it died and didn't seem that he was that engaged in activities other than science.
Okay, well, I have a little list of personality characteristics that are often assigned to the point out that I'm hoping you would reflect on some of these.
Okay.
The first one is work ethic.
Oh, he was very industrious.
Very industrious.
He worked all the time.
As a matter of fact, I remember going to parties at his house in Port Old Valley and using the restaurant, the bathroom.
And oftentimes, if you go into someone's bathroom, you'll find prevention magazine, a reader's digest, or entertainment weekly, or time, or the newspaper or something.
And Paulings bathroom was stack of journals, scientific journals.
Well, I think it goes about saying that he was extraordinarily creative and had an interesting way of visualizing and thinking about scientific problems and issues.
So I think in terms of creativity, I can't think that at least in the scientific realm that he's surpassed by anyone, really.
When you think about the nature of his stunning contributions to molecular medicine, molecular biology, chemical bond, I don't think he gets much more creative than that.
His memory was prodigious.
It's rare that you encounter someone who has such a clear memory of so many details.
And Pauling was very frequently able to recite the co-authors of papers that had been published, not just his own papers, but other papers that had been published 30, 40 years earlier, the date and the journal.
And basically could give you an abstract of that particular paper.
So he had an incredible memory, and I think that is one of the reasons he was able to make so much progress in science.
He was able to conjure facts from deep in his memory about perhaps unrelated topics and fit them together in a real synergistic way and make new discoveries.
But I have felt my father also had a stunning memory.
I won't say it was photographic, but it was close to being a photographic. He was able laid in life to remember things that he had learned as an undergraduate at Massachusetts Institute of Technology that I found very surprising.
I would try to stump him with calculus problems when he was a businessman and he was not stumpable.
And Pauling was very similar, perhaps even better than my father on the memory score.
How would he go?
Well, I think Linus Pauling had a healthy ego. I think he was well aware of his abilities.
Some people I think misinterpret that confidence in his own abilities as arrogance, and I never really interpreted that way.
It seemed to me that he knew what he was talking about.
He was able to justify his opinion or his statements about various issues which he was talking.
And I think he had a very healthy ego.
Did you ever see an angry?
Let's see.
I'm not sure that I ever saw him angry.
I saw him when he was less than happy, but I'm not sure that that would qualify as angry.
I've seen him concerned and maybe sad, but I'm not really angry.
Although I'm sure you get, for instance, during the Mayo Clinic in Brollio in the late 1970s and mid 1980s he had every right to be very angry.
And perhaps he expressed his anger to some of the participants in that controversy, but I never saw him angry.
He tended to move somewhat slowly.
Sometimes that was because he was carrying a heavy box with him with correspondence and books and paper.
So he never really seemed to be fatigued. He wasn't physically vigorous.
At the time I knew him at the Lines Points 2 Science and Medicine, but he certainly didn't seem fatigued,
but he was not physically dynamic person.
How did he handle disappointment?
There were a lot of grant applications in the late 1970s.
Yeah, I think he was disappointed, clearly, and all the emotions that go along were being disappointed.
But he never felt ejected because I think he felt that he knew better than many of the people who were denying him the grant funds.
And knew what was required to participate in the grant funding game and was playing it.
And he was disappointed that he wasn't rewarded by playing the game appropriately and the way he'd been told to play it by the funding agencies.
So he was somewhat shagrin that he couldn't get the money from federal agencies to do the kind of research that he felt was very important.
I didn't see him angry at particular people, but he was unhappy that he couldn't get financial support to do work that he felt would be very important in public health.
For instance, the vitamin C and cancer work is a case in point.
When Cameron had started treating terminal cancer patients hospitalized, waiting to die with high dose, intravenous, and oral vitamin C,
and reported to the polling that some of these people were having very dramatic responses.
Paulian Cameron collected a lot of the data, pathology, histology, x-rays, so forth.
And the polling felt that that data was probably persuasive enough to get the National Cancer Institute to set up randomized placebo-controlled double-blind clinical trial to test the efficacy of vitamin C and cancer.
Learn more about it.
And the reception he got by the NCI was very negative.
And they always found a reason that maybe vitamin C wasn't responsible for this response.
Maybe it was coincident with something else.
And Paulian said, well, that's exactly why I want these clinical trials to be carried out to find out whether this has value.
And if, totally, we have the evidence that has value, now we need to find out whether it does truly have value.
And NCI had sort of an odd perspective on the problem.
They wanted Paulian to apply for funds to study this in cell cultures and animals, animal models, like mice or rats.
So Cameron already had some clinical evidence, but they wanted to turn the wheelbarrow upside down and start with cell cultures and animals.
So typically, the normal scientific trajectory would be to establish biological plausibility and see effects in cell culture models.
And then move on into animal models to find out if you can replicate the in vitro results in an in vivo model.
And then if that's all promising, then you move eventually into a clinical translation of this modality.
And Paulian and Cameron were actually starting at the end of that tri-partate paradigm.
And he wasn't anxious to go back and start with cell cultures and the animals.
So it was, I think, excuse me, a bit frustrating to him and to learn to you and Cameron that they were being forced to start at the beginning when they already had results in people.
It seemed to be very promising and they believed would be sufficient to set up a randomized clinical trial to test this in people.
Were you in all, privy to or involved, or and I was ever to grab a fair doubt, he's collaboration with Paulian.
Well, Robert Paredowski, of course, visited the Institute many times because he was,
Paulian's official biographer.
So he came to talk with Paulian, talk with Dorothy Monroe, talk with people, colleagues at the Institute and elsewhere, many, many times over the years.
And I got to know him reasonably well.
I never had much input there.
I believe I may have spoken to him in the 1990s about some of the litigation and Robinson and rap issues.
I really don't know the status of the biography.
I have no idea.
I wish a grin to learn at one point that he had no book contract.
And it seems to me that if you have a book contract then that implies deadline and you've got to have a product by a certain date that the publisher is interested in producing.
I was surprised to find that apparently Robert Paredowski never had a book contract and was doing this presumably in hopes of shopping and around the different publishers at some later date.
But I think a book contract would have really been terrific catalysts to get in that project completed.
Tom Hager, I talked with him, I like his book very much actually.
I think it's probably the best biography of wine is falling.
And Tom of course had some access to falling late in his career and visited the Institute several times.
And I was interested in, I thought that the last chapter in the end of the book to coincide with the end of the polling life was perhaps a little bit abrupt.
And it was interested in working with Tom to develop that a little bit more thoroughly,
especially with respect to the rapid litigation.
But I think the publisher was interested in getting the book on the shelves.
Excuse me, not long after Linus plunged death in August of 1994.
And I think the book appeared in the fall of 1994.
So I think that they were interested in wrapping it up and getting it out there to sell.
While polling was still in recent memory in the news because that would have been a good marketing opportunity for them.
And I have since talked with Tom although I don't know if he has any desire to do this or his publisher has any desire to do this in
Perhaps a new edition of his book which would wrap up some of the loose ends that were left dangling in the original book.
He has published a book written of course.
Thanks.
Does that have a little bit more to do?
No, I didn't know that.
No, very interesting.
How about the drizzles or anything?
No.
No, I never had any contact as far as I can remember with Seraphini or the Gertzels.
I read their books.
I thought they were interesting.
I mean, I think no book is perfect and all have some failures or defects.
And I think those two books have their share of failures and defects.
But I couldn't call and use the media here today.
Well, I think polling as a result of his campaign to end atmospheric testing of nuclear weapons
and his political activities in the 1950s learned pretty well how to use the media.
And I was struck by his facility with the media.
I mean, he gave hundreds or thousands of interviews to journalists and media representatives throughout his life.
And he knew what the audience was and he knew what part of the story to give to the particular interviewer for that particular audience.
And he was extremely good at describing pretty complex scientific phenomena in ways that perhaps the average intelligent person can understand and grasp them.
He was a terrific speaker and was able to distill pretty complicated ideas down to easily digestible communications.
I mean, what are instances that you may remember that we're calling David.
I mean, did you make a publication that you used to use on a frequent one fall from that?
No, what?
A frequent one fall or a bump in the amount of correspondence you're receiving right?
Yeah, that's interesting.
Well, of course, during the male clinic in Brolyo, there was quite a lot of communication between the public and the institute and the line is falling because at that time,
although Cameron and Pauling pointed out that Craig and Mortel who organized and carried out that male clinic, those male clinic studies too, which were published, had not really read Cameron or Pauling's papers.
And we're not prepared to reproduce Cameron's work, technically.
So they never gave any vitamin C interventionously.
And there were other problems with male clinic studies that have been dealt with that length by other people.
So when people heard that the famous male clinic had apparently objectively evaluated high dose vitamin C cancer and came up with negative findings, there was kind of a flood of questions about this.
And Pauling and Cameron had prepared criticism of the male clinic studies, and those were provided to people who were interested.
I think that the only, I can't remember exactly big windfalls, financial windfalls to the institute from the direct male program as a result of public statements by Linus Pauling or other people at the Linus Pauling Institute of Science and Medicine, but I do remember that there were negative consequences from both the male clinic studies.
And somewhat later when people discovered that the institute was doing work on HIV, not AIDS, but HIV infection, cell culture work and the effect of vitamin C in inhibiting replication of the virus, responsible for AIDS.
There were people that had moral problems with that work for whatever reason.
And some donations dropped off as a result of that.
What do you hear since the following attitude was, of course, might especially in this young life?
Well, yeah, I don't think money was an issue for him, at least during the time I knew him, on the latter third of his life.
I feel fairly confident in saying that he didn't have any personal money problems. He loaned money to the institute many times, directed royalties from books to come to the institute, so if he had needed money personally, I don't think he would have done that, for instance.
So to me, he seemed like a very generous person, financially. He was giving money to the institute. He was trying to find money for the institute to carry out research that he felt was important.
So he seemed to be very generous and altruistic. He never seemed to be entrusted in doing anything that would raise money for him.
For instance, the patents that he was involved in acquiring weight and life, one in superconductivity, and then patents related to liberal protein A and vitamin C.
I think the goal there was not to enrich himself, but to find more revenue streams for the institute so that it could do research that he felt was important.
So I would say that's very philanthropic attitude, very altruistic.
Would you be traveling on?
Let's see.
No, I guess I didn't. I traveled with him to City Hall in Palo Alto from his apartment, and I would often show for him from his apartment at the Stanford Campus to the Lightest Poly Institute, and take him home in the evening.
Mainly because although his driver's license was still valid, he had decided not to drive so much anymore, and it gave me an opportunity to talk with him about scientific issues and administrative issues,
and he could regal me with stories from his past and kind of a distraction of free environment, namely in the car while I was driving.
But that's the extent of my travel with him, local travel.
Well, in the early 90s, he developed the illness.
It would eventually take his wife to try to treat that with an external treatment.
Well, when he went public with the diagnosis of prostate cancer, of course many people were shocked, especially his critics.
They weren't shocked, I think they were, well, I don't want to be too critical of them, but many people said we've been advocating
vitamin C for all these years and taking vitamin C for all these years and now you've got cancer.
How do you explain that?
And probably had a very rational, non-defensive response, which was most elderly men develop hyperplastic or hyperplasia in their prostate.
Most elderly men at autopsy are found to have cancerous cells in their prostate, and it's just not uncommon.
It happens to many, many elderly men, and he said it's quite likely, although not provable, and I'm paraphrasing, that his high intake of vitamin C delayed the inevitable by 20 years and more.
Because he died at the age of 93 and a half, and of course many men start to develop prostate problems 20 years earlier than that.
So it's not a provable assertion, but I think it's just as reasonable as any other assertion about their relationship with vitamin C to his cancer.
He treated himself both with high dose vitamin C, although I believe he did not take intravenous vitamin C, perhaps just oral vitamin C, which is a little surprising, but on the other hand, the pharmacokinetics of vitamin C had not been really clearly worked out, and this was before the vitamin C transporters had been discovered.
So no one really knew exactly how vitamin C got from the gastrointestinal tract into the bloodstream and to cells and tissues.
It's clear that not all of it get into the bloodstream from a large and gested dose.
Some was excreted, some that got absorbed was excreted, and some just passed through the intestinal tract.
So the pharmacokinetics were not well understood, and it wasn't until after Pony died, that people started to look into that more carefully.
And we now know, for instance, that there are active transport molecules on cells in the intestine that limit the amount of vitamin C that gets taken up by cells and move from the intestine into the bloodstream.
So when you take large oral doses, you cannot get the same blood concentration of vitamin C that you can get when you get it intravenously, because then you bypass these transporters on cells and get the vitamin C directly into the bloodstream.
And some work actually a lot of work suggests that one of the major anti-cancer mechanisms of high dose vitamin C is the generation of hydrogen peroxide, as a result of either auto oxidation of vitamin C or reactions of vitamin C with metals.
And this seems to be selective to tumor cells, and the hydrogen peroxide diffuses into the tumor cells and disrupts their cellular machinery by different mechanisms.
That wasn't really well known when Pony was self-medicating with vitamin C for his prostate cancer.
So he didn't prefer intravenous vitamin C at that point, because it wasn't any perhaps clear or rational for it.
I know that he had surgery, he underwent a bilateral orchectomy, and also was taken fluidumide, which is a standard chemotherapy drug for prostate cancer.
And I know that he was also working with friends and colleagues at Stanford Medical School to raise monoclonal antibodies against his prostate cancer cells.
And I don't really know how those things work sequentially or whether he was combining some of those modalities.
I'm not clear about that, but I know that all those avenues were tried by him.
And he was actually quite public about his treatment and about his illness.
I do recall the last thing he saw in his mind.
I believe the last time I saw him was when he was deposed by our lawyers in 1994.
I think it was early summer, late spring, early summer of 1994, at his home in Dear Flat Ranch.
What are you, what is your, what are you, memories of this, you know?
Well, it's tough to have clear memories of such an emotional event.
Linus Pauling was an unusual public figure in that many people who didn't even know him felt very strongly about him.
Either possibly, or in some cases, negative way perhaps.
And people who knew him really tended to love him because he was such a charming, magnanimous, and wonderful person to be around.
And when he died, I think everybody that knew him was grief-stricken, myself included.
And it was very difficult, I was asked to speak at that funeral as was the president of Stanford University,
or at Casper, and a number of other people.
And it was very difficult to maintain composure and talk about Linus Pauling at that event.
Well, the immediate fallout was probably a rise in memorial contributions in honor of Linus Pauling.
We were, of course, very concerned about the long-term success of the Linus Pauling Institute,
because many people who had contributed money believed rightly so in many cases that Linus Pauling was at the helm of the ship,
and he was directing the research, and he was director of research at the end of his life.
And we were concerned that absent Linus Pauling, people might start to lose interest in the Linus Pauling Institute and stop supporting it financially.
And we had no endowment at the time, and we had some zoning problems with the building in Palo Alto.
We were, you know, least building, and a commercially zone site in 440 page mail road,
which was scheduled to change to residential zoning.
So we knew we had to move, and absent Linus Pauling, no endowment and moving, was quite a challenge for the Institute.
And I alluded to this earlier, the Board of Trustees, Linus Pauling Jr. myself, really grappled for a long time with these issues,
thinking about different opportunities and options for relocation.
And ultimately, decided to come to an academic institution,
because academic institutions, except for a few, tend to be permanent.
And we started to look at academic institutions that were doing work that was compatible with Linus Pauling Institute of Science and Medicine's mission,
where this work in North and Molecular Medicine would find a good home and be able to be carried out as a working tribute to Linus Pauling's ideas in North and Molecular Medicine.
Very lucky for us during those deliberations, we were the happy recipients of a number of large bequest.
And those bequest allowed us to establish at least a small endowment, I shouldn't say endowment,
to have enough money to fund an endowment for the Directors Chair here at the Linus Pauling Institute at Oregon State University,
which at that time was matched by the state.
So it was a functional $3 million dollar endowment, which allowed us to attract very high caliber director.
And subsequently, the help of the research officer at Oregon State University,
we were able to attract high caliber faculty as well.
Well, that's the end of my set of questions on the point.
I guess I'll just ask you if there's anything else about the point of personality or personal characteristics,
or the relation between you and your student and your student.
Well, I think I've said before, I found him to be very funny.
He was very charming, very witty, of course.
I seem to know everyone, know everything.
He was just a joy to be around.
And maybe I mentioned in our last interview that when Zelle Kerman and I had finally succeeded in producing some material
and a superconductivity project that we all thought would exhibit a higher superconduct temperature
to see the expression of delight on Pauling's face when we showed him the material that we produced
was extremely memorable.
I have vivid memories of that because he was just as gleeful as a teenager on a first date
to show him that material.
He just had a real joy for scientific discovery.
And I think that was the thing that most motivated him in life.